hello I'm Gavin I'm Dan we're the slow
mo guys and today we're doing slo-mo
support Ryan Texas red one poor one asks
what's your favorite video that you
recorded for slimmer guys I certainly
like the ones where you do something
ridiculous like erupting from a six-foot
balloon of water or jumping into a
thousand mousetrap there's one where we
did like a competition we basically
tried to get into these giant balloons
and do like a competition to have the
best pose
I honestly that's one of the funniest
videos I think we've done down got into
the balloon and all the air leaked out
so it's actual it's just trapped in a
balloon just completely trapped you
could have just left me that's one of
the few times I literally rolled on the
floor laughs over there
almost suffocating like I just had this
little hole to breathe through I was
like give me more yeah you were yelling
me because I wasn't putting the leaf
blower in forever
I was just too busy laughs yeah you're
just on the floor not helping and that
bit nothing to do with the slow-mo it
was just us getting ready I mean the
slow-mo is all right yeah I think for
the super slow show my favorite was
probably the det cord because I always
wanted to film that in slow-mo always
massive shockwave not easy to get hold
of donating cord I would say outside of
the super slow show I like the one where
we put powder paint on all the airbags
it was really in the video I said it was
as if the Muppets caught in an airstrike
yes it was that colorful yeah rad it
asks what are the best slow-motion
scenes of all time I like the entirety
of insect no no oh okay you're gonna say
the movie that you filmed oh oh yeah
that was the best close to because I
worked on it yeah should have said that
I was like no ignore him there's some
cool ones in Dredd I like the drug that
was in it this or a whole whole point of
it was around slow-motion so some
awesome scenes there I worked in that
one didn't did you really I actually
hated throughout it was terrible I know
Elizabeth
Zeena asks why is everyone so obsessed
with filming things in slow motion
lately or starting in regular speed then
slow motion then regular that's cool
annoying hashtag annoying because it
looks
wicked it's wrong with you Lisbeth
everything looks cooler in slow-mo yeah
a paint dry hashtag annoys think we're
done with that question
Tony turn side asks what about sound do
you always just use the sound slowed
down or do you mix slashed
sound design I would say the sound
design is by far the most time-consuming
part of making these videos what I'll do
is I'll sometimes slow the sound down as
much as I can say if there was a
something landing on the ground and you
need that sound off
I'll just retime that so that fits and
then I'll just add in other sound
effects and I put in that sort of
background hum to hide empty spaces
where there's no sound I'm at one time a
very early video we had a lighter on a
BBQ in your garden in England we sort of
just set it on fire and it blew up and
they like to span hundreds of times and
I remember you telling me that all you
did was go I think I went and I just
loaded down it was like more so
sometimes it's just my mouth so it's
like completely made up essentially
simply the thing is now you unless
people watch this they will think that
that's the noise that things make they
don't know it's actually your mouth
tails at hey I'm tails asks where do you
guys get the tonnes of food for the
super-slow show is it donated or old
food asking for a friend the friend is
man I like we just used to go over to
the craft services table and all the
stuff that was about to be tucked away
we just take it and sometimes none of
the crew had any food left to eat let me
come to lunchtime and there'd be no
water nerds yeah but a lot the time we
tried to catch the food after it
exploded or something I know I'm eating
food post-explosion as well I would say
UV and more exploded food than most
humans I actually think that might be
true I think I must have eaten more
blown-up food than anyone else so
refreshing
clueless will ya asks what is the worst
experience of filming for a video well I
think that's a me question because Gavin
who only all he does is still stand
behind the camera and watch me do the
bad stuff according to Dan all I do is
press the button he just does this and
then that and then I have to like do all
the work but I'd say
you know I've done so many things like
jumping into a thousand mousetraps on a
trampoline on the super slow show I
tried to impress Tony Hawk and I broke
my wrist and I did a belly flop from
about 12 foot higher
I've been burnt I've had my ears torn
quite a lot of painful things that have
to be unpleasant like puke and milk up I
stubbed my toe once as bad as that stuff
is it's great content I would say the
worst experience is when we go through
this massive long setup or you go
through something like that and the
footage doesn't look any good because
then we get crabby Sundeep suresh says
what's your process like when you're
trying to create a new idea for a video
because we live in separate countries we
only shoot like three times a year so
when we're not shooting more slowly
building this list
maybe it's tough the viewers have sent
to us maybe it's something we've seen on
reddit or I'll just be in the shower and
I have an idea or something and then
when we finally get together we'll have
this massive list and we'll then decide
which ones we want to do in that filming
session and then we'll go shopping for
props you know I'll go and buy some what
balloons paint and melon melons as rills
yeah one of the big selling points for
us with the super slow show was that we
were able to do stuff we've never been
able to do before and we're also able to
revisit stuff and scale it up massively
the episode was actually called double
it where we were doubling up on our
previous experiments and one of my
favorite ones was the paint drill I mean
we first used a normal drill and then I
thought well what we're actually after
is just spinning paint we don't
necessarily need to store paint on a
drill bit because you can't really hold
that much so I came up with the idea to
have a PVC pipe separate into four
different chambers with slits cut into
it and we were just fill it with paint
and then use a drill to power that to
spin and it looks insane and there's
some things we just physically couldn't
fit in the garden there's a video with
Andy Bell coming up where he rides a
motorbike across a pool first of all we
don't pull a bike or enemy down any
skills so that's kind of impossible but
we would love to us in and we did so
it's really sweet another thing I wanted
to do with the super slow show was
different camera techniques stuff that
we've never been taught to do before and
that involved mounting the camera on
moving objects like Andy Bell's head or
spinning it on a spinning rig looking
inwards to create a sort of bullet-time
effect there's a special robotic arm
that we've had the chance to use before
where it essentially holds the camera
and swings around really quickly but we
had an entirely new gym we could put
much bigger subjects like ex-player trap
with a soda bottle in the middle of it
because a lot the time when you've got
one camera or two cameras you you're
locked into those angles and there might
be interesting stuff happening on the
back or the other side I honestly I wish
we could have spun it faster but it got
to the point where because the cameras
so heavy if we cranked it up all the way
the arm bent and all the cables snapped
yeah we were on the brink will push
nothing right the word bald guy says
Andy Williams is this the best
slow-motion explosion ever he asked Oh
first of all one of my favorite it is
brilliant because we had these bangers
in the UK and they're way more powerful
than the bangers you get here it's like
an maa times 10 yeah but we put it in
the water and it was just sort of
expecting it to sort of go put her and
it exploded perfectly so they looked
like a planet that was just perfectly
just being annihilated
we rarely test stuff not on camera and
at that point we might as well just go
for anyway might as well just film it
and present it as an episode we should
have tested that because any less and it
would have just split the melon any more
powerful would have missed it the moment
but it perfectly fragments it
unfortunately a lot of it went into your
face
Kristen Koppel asks weekend's at our
house sometimes involved building
small-scale models and filming their
destruction in slow motion future
engineers or filmmakers or both I used
to love doing stuff like that I like
that people spend their weekend doing
this is good that's such a cool project
I wish I had that kind of technology
when I was a kid at mark Hilary asks
filming an electrical storm with my
iPhone in slow motion mode and I can see
lightning in front of me and where I'm
pointing the phone on a tripod yeah the
recording has nothing is it too fast for
the phone to record something about
Sarah lightning is very very fast the
speed of light or is the fastest thing
in it but yeah you can absolutely miss a
lightning strike or because of rolling
shutter you might get sort of one half
of the image very bright and blown out
and the other half it hasn't happened
yet sort of thing you can record it with
much higher frame rates though maybe you
know towards 50,000 the actual strike
comes up from the earth so from the
cloud you get a bunch of
tiny thin lining tendrils yeah the first
one that hits the ground then sends the
big lightning strike back up yeah it's
insane to watch as long I mean one day
maybe they'll have phones that do 50,000
frames a second yeah that's maybe when
we're in future yeah
CL H or Chris LH 1987 I was born you
after that fun facts Gavin free
concealer motion video be live-streamed
in a situation where the camera will
knowingly be destroyed by whatever it's
filming all the cameras we use record
internally to ram so if we use any of
our cameras you're probably going to hit
your footage and destroy all doesn't
need cameras are expensive you wanna
turn attraction one of the front and V
series cameras there's like a central
head and then cameras come out of it
just the heads of the cameras come out
of it you can ruin the camera part and
keep the data I mean you can live stream
the feed from the camera that you would
then have to switch it to playback to
playback the slow-mo current live stream
every frame Daz Dillinger asks why do
lights flicker when video is in slow
motion that's due to the frequency of
electricity so in the u.s. it's 60 Hertz
so normal lights like the ones in here
are actually turning on and off 60 times
every second which you can't see with
your eye because the interval when
they're off is so brief you when you're
filming a thousands of frames a second
they'll be pulsing oh yeah that's one of
the biggest issues when when shooting
slow-mo indoors is that you need big
lights you're talking about 5,000 watts
probably because at that size when the
lights are turning off that they're so
big and the filament is so big that
there's not actually enough time for
them to cool enough to dim so you just
need big fat really hot lights looking
very cool Ken Gibson with your beard and
your cigarette out the mouth looking
badass I'm sure you have tons of ideas
for slow-mo guys but have you ever
considered doing a somewhat gross out
series with things like a popping pimple
we did me poking up some milk we go we
don't vomit that was gross we tried
filming a pimple but it didn't really
explode it just sort of like didn't
really do anything I have a pretty
sensitive gag reflex - yeah and you
don't want you know when you film and be
like that's what you do is what it is
Andy you Ferguson asks you ever thought
of forming a grenade going off
underwater in slow motion oh sure
ballistics gel with different things a
grenade we didn't like do I have any
grenades I don't have one you don't I'm
fresh out unfortunately it's very hard
to get a hold of a fragment I'd like a
military grenade yeah it's also
unnecessary all it is is just needing an
explosion underwater which we have
filmed with bangers on a much smaller
scale although because it slow motion it
kind of looks bigger than it actually is
we've never done ballistics gel we're
trying to do too much stuff with live
ammo this is Curtis it's scary he's good
TD TV asks what kind of lenses do you
guys use the lenses that we use depend
on the camera the different cameras we
use have different mounts so whenever we
borrow the V 25:11 that has a Canon
mount so I whip my Canon lenses I try
and use primes because they're a lot
faster lenses clicking a more wide open
and I sometimes need the light for our
phantom Flex 4k we use PA lenses which
are unfortunately much more expensive
and much bigger and we use primes again
just because you can open them up more
yeah we've also used macro lenses I used
that to film the pixels in my TV and the
hair follicles in Dan's leg my legs have
recovered actually nice day I've got
lots of hair back I was paying for on it
yeah
and he kept messing it up so we kept
having to do it well the thing is on a
macro lens your depth is nothing so I'd
be framing up on some hair follicles and
I'd whip the thing off but it would pull
up the skin skin move the skin towards
the camera which would pull it
completely out of focus can you just do
it except not so like much yeah humans
are a bit too fleshy to use macro lenses
I've progressed
Pennywise loka asks if money was no
object what's the one video you would
want to make something in space maybe an
Aston Martin doing a corkscrew into a
helicopter or something well that's just
to make a dial necessarily waste money's
no object could just be any other car
into anything else yeah we had the money
to buy a new planet and self like a huge
new okay right okay well I don't know
I'm trying to come up with money no
object then fine so they're gonna say
impossible what is the money no object
is there a place where you can buy a new
planet and blow it up a long-nosed
Royale really okay
Oliver underscore crush asks what is the
best way to make good slow-motion videos
with a low budget well conversely
actually I would say that our slow-mo
videos have an incredibly low budget the
most important thing with slow merry is
you need a lot of light so go outside
probably well that was fun thank you so
much for your questions we had a lovely
time answering them be sure to check out
the super slow show you can find it on
YouTube on our channel subscribe to the
slow mo guys because that's where it is
down gets hurt
yeah